après une longue période de
le temps va nettement sur
cyr et ce redoux va s'accompagner
le nord ouest de la france d'un temps
agités tourmenté un coup de vent va
balayer tout le littoral de la manche de
la pointe bretonne jusqu'à la belgique
le vent va souffler de plus en plus fort
et puis demain c'est une véritable
tempête qui va frapper la france et oui
c'est klaus qui va frapper la france ce
24 janvier 2009
klaus oui merci klaus qui est qui est en
train de mijoter sur l'atlantique
il ya beaucoup d'incertitude alors on va
essayer de comprendre quelles sont ces
incertitudes et comment j'ai vécu ce le
passage de cette tempête klaus sur notre
pays et cette tempête klaus elle était
extrêmement violente et vous avez vu
tous les dégâts qu'elle a fait et le
vendredi on n'était encore pas très sûr
qu'elle puisse se développer qu'elle
puisse se former d'abord pourquoi klaus
c'est pas un prénom qui avait été donnée
par la france mais c'est un prénom qui
est donnée par nos amis allemands et si
vous voulez que votre prénom soit
affecté à une des pressions et
l'anticyclone il suffit de nous envoyer
un petit mail à l'université de berlin
ça coûte quelques euros pour un
anticyclone parce qu'on n'en parle pas
beaucoup et un peu plus cher pour une
dépression parce qu'on n'en parle plus
souvent
donc voilà donc nous on donne pas de
noms assez assez assez tempête alors
donc il ya le vendredi encore de très
grosses inquiétudes dans les locaux de
météo france parce que on envisage la
formation d'une dépression dans le golfe
de gascogne la dépression dans le golfe
de gascogne en a souvent mais celle ci
elle semble dangereuse elle semble
versatile parce qu elle l est elle est
très très complexe or qu'est ce qu'il
est en train de se passer dans
l'atmosphère avant comprendre qu'on
prenne cette décision mais vous avez
dans l'atmosphère ce qu'on appelle des
jets je sais pas si vous avez entendu
parler de jet stream
ce sont des tubes de vents forts qui
servent à l'aviation pour traverser
beaucoup plus vite
l'atlantique quand on vient des
etats-unis vers la france on peut gagner
jusqu'à une heure de vol et ses jets ce
sont des tubes devant très très fort dit
1500 mètres d'altitude puis ça ça ondule
au dessus de l'océan
j'avais à peu près quelques centaines de
2 2 mètres de diamètre et plusieurs
milliers de kilomètres de long et ce
jour là sur l'atlantique
on a un serpent qui est en train d'en du
lait avec des vents qui est à
l'intérieur de ce serpent souffle à 300
kilomètres par heure et puis en dessous
se balade des petites dépressions dire
des petits système dépressionnaire qui
sont en train de se balader et il ya
certains
modèle on verra tout à l'heure ce que
c'est un modèle mais à certains modèles
qui font passer la dépression sous le
serpent et quant à des pressions passe
sous le serpent comme sont des
mouvements ascendants sous la dépression
mais il ya une espèce d'aspiration qui
est fait avec le tube de vents très
forts et là vous avez une baisse de
pression qui est extrêmement brutal la
dépression se creuse et ça devient une
très grosse tempête une bombe
météorologique
et puis sur certains modèles la petite
la petite dépression elle passe à côté
il se passe rien et sur d'autres modèles
elle frôle seulement le tube de vents
forts elle explose pas mais elle devient
un peu plus virulente donc le choix
le vendredi 23 janvier de l'ensemble des
prévisionnistes de météo france
c'était de dire où va passer cette
dépression est ce qu'elle se passe sous
le tube sous ce fameux serpent de tubes
de vent fort et là c'est un choix qui
est difficile à faire parce qu'il ya des
modèles qui effectivement ne donnait pas
de solution pour le passage de cette
tempête donc un choix est fait on se dit
que la tempête va effectivement passé à
la dépression va effectivement passé sur
le tube et que donc cette tempête dans
le golfe de gascogne va exploser et
devenir un phénomène majeur donc ce une
fois qu'on a envisagé le phénomène
majeur on a fait un choix on est comme
un funambule qui a plusieurs solutions
et qui est obligé de choisir la bonne
pour aller du point a vers le point b
donc on a fait un choix en a pris la
solution du funambule qui choisit le
trajet qui va nous mener à une puissante
tempête il faut que vous avez fait le
choix il faut trouver faut trouver les
moyens d'avertir la population de
prévenir l'ensemble des acteurs pour
essayer d'avoir le moins de victimes
possible et d'essayer d'avoir
effectivement des prévisions qui soit de
d'excellente qualité
donc la pression est en train de monter
et puis l'après midi on commence à
passer en vigilance rouge 5 puis 9
départements
et puis bien sûr on prévient l'ensemble
des acteurs concernés par le passage de
cette tempête là il ya plein plein
d'acteurs vous avez tous les pouvoirs
publics
vous avez les df vous avez des
transports aériens les transports
routiers et les transports ferroviaires
vous avez les assurances qui sont
également intéressés pour connaître le
passage d'un tel événement et puis vous
avez la sécurité civile qui est chargé
de la mise en place de moyens avec tous
les préfets et la ministre de
l'intérieur qui pour le cas a été
présenté a mis en place
a demandé à ce que soit mise en place un
nombre de moyens très impressionnant
pour pouvoir éviter un des victimes pour
cette tempête on avait des hélicoptères
sur la région de bordeaux
des hélicoptères sur la région de
montpellier des hôpitaux de campagne qui
ont été mis en place avec à peu près
1000 personnes qui avaient été mobilisés
pour cet événement donc voilà le
contexte on a pris la décision on est
passés en vigilance orange on a
déclenché on indiqué avoir une tempête
et puis quand on s'en va avec mon
collègue le soir bon la nuit la journée
a été très très longue
on s'en va avec mon collègue le soir et
puis on se dit ah oui mais si le modèle
qui avait annoncé le passage à côté du
du serpent la dépression il a raison
demain est rien il n'y a pas de tempête
donc on a mis en place des moyens on a
fait mettre en place des moyens
impressionnants et il n'y a pas de
tempête
donc on rentre chez nous et bien sûr la
nuit a été très courte 1 on a suivi jean
particulièrement moi j'ai suivi la
situation régulièrement et en regardant
sur internet l'évolution des paramètres
météo en me disant va-t-il de vata
va-t-elle exploser va-t-elle de naître
cette fameuse tempête et à partir de
minuit à partir de minuit je commence à
regarder les observations de cette
tempête qui commencent à s'organiser
et effectivement elle passe sous le tube
et en passant sur le tube sur la galice
nord de l'espagne sur les cantabriques
en galice le vent commence à atteindre
219 kilomètres par heure en rafales
ça commence à devenir déjà très
impressionnant
et puis vers 3 heures du matin bordeaux
le vent commence à augmenter le vent
commence à augmenter en vitesse en
dépassant les 100 kilomètres heure du
côté du cap ferret et du côté de
bordeaux puis d'un seul coup à trois
heures du matin
cent soixante et un kilomètres heure en
rafales sur bordeaux donc ça y est une
autre explosion a eu lieu
et puis maintenant cette tempête va
glisser vers le midi toulousain vers la
méditerranée en passant entre le massif
central et les pyrénées qui jouera un
peu un effet d'accélérateur et ensuite
158 km dans le courant de la matinée
a narbonne 191 c'est la valeur la plus
élevée qu'on ait eu en france
191 kilomètres heure du côté de
perpignan donc une grande joie de voir
cette tempête
bien prévu finalement mais une grosse
inquiétude quand même parce que qu'est
ce qui se passe derrière vous savez
quand vous êtes sur l'autoroute il
roulait à 130 si vous passez le voir à
travers la fenêtre votre bras il
emportait à imaginer ce que c'est à 190
on n'y va jamais 1 190 donc on se rend
pas bien compte de la puissance du vent
et de la vitesse que peuvent atteindre
ces vents dans une dans une tempête
aussi impressionnante donc grande
inquiétude et joie d'avoir fait une
bonne prévision granier inquiétude parce
que parce que cette tempête va avoir
malheureusement des conséquences bien
sûr comme d'habitude quand il ya un
événement pareil des dégâts assez
importants 1 million 800 mille à peu
près personne privée d'électricité
il ya eu 600 700 mille hectares de forêt
qui ont été détruits 400 blessés et 12
victimes
alors 12 victimes là là effectivement
c'est le côté négatif delà de la bonne
prévision pourquoi y at il encore des
victimes lorsque l'on à des événements
comme ça qu'on était suffisamment
anticipé et suffisamment envisagée est
tout simplement parce que c'est
difficile quand je vous pose la question
est ce que vous croyez tout ça les
prévisions météo non ils se trompent
tout le temps ils ont pris le parapluie
ils sont encore bourré et puis et puis
c'est samedi
c'est samedi il faut sortir il faut
aller faire les courses et là on va
faire les courses
il faut aller manger chez la belle-mère
va manger chez la belle-mère
on va acheter du pain parce qu'on a
besoin d'acheter du pain et quel que
soit l'événement
si on a programmé la veille un trajet
une une activité on ne va pas la
supprimer à cause de cet événement
météorologique donc une mauvaise prise
de conscience de la population de
l'événement proprement dit et dans les
victimes qu'il ya eu sur cet épisode là
les 12 victimes
ce sont ce sont essentiellement des
victimes par imprudence
les douze victimes vous avez des gens
qui sont tombées du toit parce qu'il
voulait remettre antennes de télé pour
un journal de 20 heures vous avez des
gens
qui sont morts électrocutés parce qu'ils
ont enlevé le petit câble qui passait
devant chez eux qu'ils étaient par terre
malheureusement il y avait encore encore
du courant dessus et le pire le pire de
tous ce sont les gens qui ont sorti pour
avoir d'électricité chez eux des groupes
électrogènes et pour pas se les faire
voler ils émettaient dans la maison
alors un groupe électrogène ça marche
avec du gasoil et ça produit bien sûr
des gaz nocifs
donc on le protège vont pas se le faire
voler et on meurt asphyxié ce qui est
fortement dommage donc il ya une forte
anticipation pour que dans l'avenir
s'il ya encore des événements comme ça
il faut qu'il n'y ait plus de victimes
du deuxième élément c'est la prévision
de la prévision météo
comment ça marche quoi qu'est ce qui se
passe pourquoi on a des difficultés
comme ça à faire ses choix alors là ça
c'est la partie la plus complexe alors
je vais essayer de vous raconter comment
ça fonctionne un modèle qu'est ce qu'un
modèle de prévision numérique
ben c'est de connaître sur l'ensemble de
la terre le temps qu'il fait un instant
donné qu'elle projetait jusqu'à une
dizaine de jours de connaître autant
qu'il va faire donc on met à la surface
du globe des couches de grillage on met
à peu près sans couche de voyage à la
surface du globe
mais voyez bien qu'entre ces couches de
grillage pour la serrer dans le baht
l'atmosphère et d'essai en altitude on
va créer des petites boîtes
donc on crée des milliards de boîtes
dont le côté de la boîte est de 10km
aidant à l'intérieur de ces boîtes on
essaye de connaître à chaque instant
d'autant qu'il fait part à m pression
température humidité est de savoir
comment ça va évoluer avec des plus des
équations physique on essaye de voir
comment ça va évoluer toutes les six
minutes jusqu'à une dizaine de jours et
jusqu'à une dizaine de jours ont fait
tourner les modèles pour connaître
l'évolution de l'atmosphère
mais à partir de ce moment là on
s'aperçoit que plus on va d'antan plus
être la dérive et on utilise des
méthodes qui nous permette de pouvoir
quantifier cette dérive de pouvoir voir
comment l'atmosphère
évolue quant à partir de trois jours il
commença à partir un peu en vrac un peu
en vrille et je vous propose de regarder
un peu les spaghettis ce qu'on appelle
non des spaghettis donc vous avez ici le
trajet d'une particule d'air qui voyage
des etats unis pratiquement jusqu'aux
confins de la russie
et on a nos 72 solution puisque vous de
prendre une solution dont 172 on se dit
qu'on va voir comment ça évolue
et lorsque vous allez voir l'image
s'arrêter vous allez voir que dans un
premier temps les 72 solution ils sont
tous elles sont toutes identiques et que
progressivement deux jours trois jours
quatre jours cinq jours six jours après
voyez cette dérive et voyez que on a des
trajectoires qui commence à dériver et
après vous avez un gribouillis d'enfants
donc il est difficile de faire des
prévisions météorologiques à une dizaine
de jours et pour cette tempête klaus
c'est ça la particularité de cette
tempête klaus c'est que la dérive
elle commençait à un jour on n'a pas pu
le faire de prévisions à un jour plutôt
qu'un jour c'est à dire qu'on a on n'a
pas envisagé 48 heures avant le passage
de cette tempête mais vraiment dans les
24 heures on a pu prévoir le passage de
cette tempête dans ce grand satisfaction
donc ça c'est le côté un peu mauvais du
vent un peu méchant du ventre qui
transporte également les virus les
parasites les maladies enfin bon ça
c'est le vent mauvais mais il ya le vent
plutôt bon le vent qui est bien le
bienfait de l'humanité qui nous apporte
plein de choses
ce vent qui va nous a permis des
découvertes vous avez depuis 3000 ans
avant jésus-christ des gens qui ont
inventé des voiliers qui ont permis de
de voyager sur les merdes se déplacer
d'aller faire du commerce
et puis vous avez le vent qui a permis
les grandes découvertes comme christophe
colomb qui a traversé l'océan
grâce au vent qui était au sud de
l'anticyclone des açores
ce qu'on appelle l'alizé et puis vous
avez bas le vent qui permet d'assainir
l'atmosphère ci avait pas de vent
l'atmosphère serait forcément malsaine
puisqu'il y aurait pas d'évacuation nous
avaient le vent qui nous permet de
produire d'électricité de produire de
l'eau potable de produire un tas de
choses qui sont bénéfiques à la nature
et bien sûr la faune la flore le vent
qui fait l'érosion qui fait la beauté de
nos paysages avec l'eau et puis ce vent
qui est donc très très utile à
l'ensemble de notre vivant très très
présent à l'ensemble de notre vivant et
puis une particularité du vent que vous
connaissez peut-être pas mais j'espère
que vous connaissez le pouls de la
planète
quel est le poumon de la planète qui
vous permet d'avoir une fourniture
d'oxygène importante et qui absorbe une
partie du co2 qu'on produit en abondance
est-ce que vous avez une idée l'océan
dans l'océan il absorbe le co2 la forêt
amazonienne
c'est la forêt le poumon de la terre
c'est la forêt amazonienne et vous savez
comment vit cette forêt amazonienne
grâce à qui vit cette forêt amazonienne
grâce au vent et que quel est le rôle du
vent dans cette forêt amazonienne
mais cette forêt amazonienne elle est
nourrie par un élément dont il étonnant
inattendue par le sable du sahara vous
prenez l'anticyclone des açores votre
vent tourner dans le secteur des açores
il a permis à france à collants de
christophe colomb découvre l amérique
mais il souffre aux arts donc ils
transportent du sable et transportent du
sable en permanence entre le sahara et
et d'amérique du sud et donc fourni de
l'engrais du phosphore en fait c'est du
phosphore qui est apportée à la forêt
saharienne fort hills a rien qui n'a pas
d'engrais naturel puisqu'il pleut
beaucoup il ya beaucoup de ruissellement
donc il ya beaucoup de terre qui s'en va
et la nourriture est apportée par le
désert du sahara
et ce désert fournit donc le sable et le
phosphore qui est nécessaire à la
nourriture de notre de notre forêt de
notre planète
donc c'est un aspect inattendu du vent
mais il est utile également bon on l'a
vu tout à l'heure dans les arts dans la
musique
il est utile pour ben pour le sel si
vous voulez avoir du sel il faut de
l'évaporation mais c'est grâce au vent
et au soleil bien sûr mais qu'il ya une
une forte évaporation donc ce vent est
très utile à la vie sur terre donc le
côté négatif c'était tempête le côté
négatif c'est également transport de
virus et et le transport de
de co2 dans la haute atmosphère mais le
bienfait du vent basse et de modeler nos
paysages et d'apporter à notre vie un
bien-être inattendu attend inattendu et
j'espère que ça sera durable en tout cas
le vent qui suit les isobar
anticyclonique qui suit les isobar
dépressionnaire comme un peu un
funambule dont je parlais tout à l'heure
ce vent j'espère que lorsque vous allez
sortir de la salle bain vous allez le
percevoir d'une manière un peu
différente et vous allez faire comme on
disait tout à l'heure une grande
respiration
merci
[Applaudissements]